the world's biggest dating show 35
countries 180 weddings and over 400
babies has arrived who is ready to fall
for a farmer hello my name is Jennifer
Nettles and I am thrilled to be the host
of the Fantastic new unscripted series
farmer wants a wife have you ever dated
a farmer no I've never dated a fire
before
this has real authentic connections
people who are looking for lifelong
Partners not just looking to become
famous it's hard to meet people when you
don't leave the farm much hopefully I
find true love what do we think of
Oklahoma it looks very abandoned finding
true love for me it's now I have a
partner someone who not only do I have
their back but they've got mine
they will spend six weeks getting to
know each other in this journey to find
love she's definitely got my attention
[Music]
she's a hoot I'll say that I get to meet
more girls in one day than I've met in
the last five years morning ladies a
little overwhelming having all the
ladies at once it's a big adjustment
foreign
what's better than love and I love real
people who are out there doing the work
I'm not the type of girl that's going to
fight and compete against other girls
I've got to go home I don't want to beg
you to stay I want you to stay this is a
hell of a lot harder than I thought it
was going to be so what made you want to
do this the end of the day no matter how
content You Are by yourself
there's just still something missing I'm
super excited to get to be a part of
this heartwarming Adventure that brings
people to
it went smooth it ended with a good kiss
you're not shy so you can't have your
cake and eat it too you can't date five
girls at the same time Mama's opinion
she's the one what's my heart saying
right now get my rear end back in there
and keep dancing with that pretty girl
[Music]